the Tesla Model 3 isn't just a new
electric car it's the culmination of
over a decade of careful strategic
planning to achieve Elon Musk's goal to
accelerate humanity's transition to
sustainable energy making the model 3 a
reality is a huge milestone for Tesla
but whether it's building the world's
largest factory or making driverless
cars real sooner than anyone else
everything Tesla has done to this point
is to set itself up for an even more
extreme future castle without Elon Musk
might be unimaginable now but he was
just one of five co-founders in 2003 the
company's first car was a sporty
all-electric two-seater roadster which
won fans with its performance and
efficiency in 2005 and Tesla sold just
under two and a half thousand of them
over four years not bad but for context
musk wants to sell 500,000 cars in 2018
the first full year of model 3
production what was unique about the
Roadster was it was the first really
great electric car and before the roads
the people thought an electric car would
be would be slow and ugly and low range
and have bad performance and we had to
break that mold it was incredibly
important to show that that wasn't true
the Roadster was just the beginning of
Elon Musk's master plan step 1
builds an expensive sports car step 2
take the money from that and build a
normal Ascar for half the price
step 3 use that money to build an
affordable high-volume car so that
everyone can go electric that would be
the model 3
the company struggled financially at
first musk poured his own money in and
stepped into the CEO role in 2008 the
next year Tesla unveiled step to the
Model S the car that Tesla would become
famous for and still its flagship today
the global financial crisis slowed plans
for Tesla deliveries of the s didn't
start until 2012 but when they finally
did the internet couldn't get enough of
the car that musk said was like having
your own private rollercoaster it could
travel up to 300 miles on a charge and
do 0 to 60 in a ludicrously fast sprint
well called the Tesla Model X step 2.5
and Musk's master plan the idea to build
an SUV as well as a car made sense on
paper buyers usually love them and will
pay a premium but the model acts with
it's stunning falcon doors was a
manufacturing nightmare for Tesla the
Model X was unveiled in 2012 with sales
to to start in 2013 around 30,000 people
put down $5,000 deposits and then waited
and waited and waited
deliveries actually started in 2015 must
now admits the complexity of the X was
hubris the company was stretching too
far too fast Tesla also faced severe
supplier parts shortages as it starts to
build the model 3 Tesla says it's
drawing on all those lessons from its
past and building a far simpler car so
now then going from the the s and the X
we finally come to it we come to us to
step 3 the final step in the in the
master plan which is a mass-market
affordable
affordable car it's also taking control
of much of its supply chain it's
building a Giga factory in Nevada which
when it's finished will be the largest
building on earth by footprint and
although it's only partly done it's
already up and running making batteries
it'll produce more lithium-ion batteries
then all other factories in the world
combined never one to hold back mosque
wants to open several of the giant
factories around the world and two to
three more in the US to keep up with the
demand the model 3 is expected to create
electric cars are just part of the
picture for Tesla though the company has
been a leader in another very important
emerging field autonomy Elon Musk wasn't
satisfied with building a super-fast
electric car he wanted to take his
computers on wheels to the next level in
October of 2015
Tesla pushed a software update that
turned on the now-famous autopilot which
allowed its cars to pretty much drive
themselves on the highway and eventually
to pull in and out of garages with
nobody inside a newer generation of
sensors and an onboard supercomputer
should be enough for full self-driving
musk says any promises to demonstrate
that with a cross-country trip by the
end of 2017 it's yet another crazily
ambitious self-imposed deadline
meanwhile Tesla is also building out its
superchargers its own network of
high-powered chargers that span the
highways of the US and other countries
and enable long-distance travel with
quick recharge times not top up your
tank quick but 20 to 40 minutes rather
than overnight they're one of the
biggest selling points to anyone who
needs an electric car to be more than a
city trekker but the current network is
already getting crowded even without the
influx of model threes Tesla says it
will double the number of chargers
worldwide and they'll be needed in 2016
must cook the wraps off the model three
all right let's bring out
step3 in his master plan the affordable
car some 375 thousand people rush to
make reservations at $1,000 each for a
car that starts at $35,000 for once
production seems to be running on
schedule but deliveries will start very
slowly the first cars coming off the
line are going to Tesla and SpaceX
employees to shake out any bugs but
eventually this is the car that will
compete with BMW or Toyota the vehicle
that Tesla hopes will prove electric
cars are usable and attainable for
everyone
Elon Musk has also teased a big rig to
be revealed later in 2017 a pickup and a
smaller SUV just because the model three
is here doesn't mean Tesla has any
intentions of slowing down